horrible hi I'm Dan Glover I can be
water bridge and we are going to be
playing snack or snuff Wars
snack fights what the hell is going on
what is that black did is basically
blood like your charms wins lucky charm
blue a statue how I was very very very
drunk like there was a statue this is
like that is everywhere and I would just
go up and I talked to them one thing no
probably something really important okay
sour sour apple mm-hmm sour apple yeah
[Music]
you have other things to do today
okay I think this is like a look you see
how much more I gave you yeah I'm sorry
I can't see you right no it's just a
loud white buzz in there and medicine
yeah it's like medicine
like going with innocently 15 and
throwing up again in some pine yeah
um today I'm gonna go the showers out
something refreshing
alright goldfish and one monstermunch
can you take no no it looks intense
I know they're gonna like Funyuns I
don't
they're like onion rings but they're
like this yeah I'm kind of already you
know what I'm gonna go with not as much
I'm gonna go in monster mother
Oh me first
no I'm Tahoe okay oh how sweet
Oh dad die hard - OH
me and I'm boots no this is good stuff
got to savory food
[Music]
don't do that oh no oh right that's
horrible that tastes to me like a
birthday like a fifth grade birthday
party and like I'm just like sitting in
the corner like why doesn't Tia like me
that kind of thing like this is so
intense I kind of like wine punch cheese
strings oh wow she's 40 strings no I
haven't here to either this he's a very
very important British people okay this
isn't as important as Raveena yeah Tommy
this is good because it's like I can see
how with like a drink or something like
that I've been especially TT want to
split one once we have money yeah
remember them thing they didn't like the
favor cake with creamy filling and
causes water and cream and not cross it
there's something about these that I
want to eat more of them this one I'm
like if these came smaller yeah so I'm
gonna go with these cookies I actually
really like these cookies cookies good
I mean I guess it wasn't a competition
on mind I just had to judge so you guys
really need to step up your game
whereas I will take some credit yeah
the success story okay good this is
really supposed to be an hour long
[Music]